Tâm lý đó, thật sự ra đã lỗi hỏi dọ.
Tâm có hai kích tâm lý, tâm lý phía nhất là tâm lý phố mộn
phía mộn lý sình ảo, ra xa bỏ mất cơ hội.
Hành ra dây dây gửi đáng thý, ra vàng lý, dây hóa cho mướng mẹ quá,
đã giảm từ đến từ kế mức một chăm năm bây lòng chưa đồng một lợp.
Vì giờ xuống còn có một chăm cũng bị tâm chưa đồng,
tâm phải bỏ nghĩ rằng tâm tâm là tệ và hiện tạc.
Bỏ tâm đến có tệ vàng, để mỏ hệ bố bàn như mỏ của gồm.
Tâm lý phố mộn lòng có tâm lý sức là phố biệt.
Tâm lý sương hai nữa là hoặc nhiều người bố đăng, hong đợi là giá gặn sẽ được hồi phục chờ lại.
Và chỉ người thấy mà rất mốt là buồn bàn tệ với nhiều mục lịch,
có những người mua bàn là chỉ đẹn lưu sọc,
buồn đi bán lại kêu ăn sổ để mà kým lợp.
Tây như mặc cũng có những người dân hỏng buồn bàn với một cái mục lịch là một cái đau từ lâu ra,
hậm chí là có thể để xưa kế cho con chấu của mẹ.
Ok, tâm lý đó tại Việt Nam rất là mại.
Dùng và hả như là một cái tài sản để không tên tệ tệ tệ và phập chi là vừa kế.
Tình vì tất cả những kế tâm lý đó mà mỏng người đều muốn văn.
Nhưng mà chúng ta phải biết là kế tâm lý đó thật sự ra đã lâu hỏi được.
Nếu chúng ta đau từ vào bạn thì nên tổ từ như là các nước đến chệ,
các nước phát chệ mại, cho họ không một cái sản và đau từ không phải là tổ từ vào văn và chất nữa.
Mà đau từ vào các chứng quan văn và chứng chỉ và mà theo nhiều thông tin là số lợp mà văn dịch tại đang ở trong cơn.
Hó thẻ lên đến 5 chăm tính bạn và nếu mà chúng ta sử dụng kế tài sản đó,
tâm và chong lên kinh tế cho hoạt động sản rất ký tránh.
Thấm bí chỉ là có thể dùng để tế chấp và văn tệ của nước ngoài.
Hãy có thể sử dụng cho phát chệ kế tệ.
Trong khi một cái số lợp văn thì tệ, chúng ta tệ em về nhà chúng ta chung rưỡi gần dường.
Chung trung xân nhà họ có thể chung tụi sắp quan toàn khu của lợi cho nên kế tệ.
Trong thời đưa là lấy đi một thương muôn lực tại chính rất lớn,
đang lý và có thể đổ vào các phía chương cánh như là phía chương trương quán như là phía chương bất trúng sản.
Hó khó khó khó gửi kiện và hôm bên hạn.
Hãy ký tài sản đó được gửi chung nhá rất nó là một cái điều hó khứng tốt cho lên kế tệ.